overnight summer camps cost anywhere
from a thousand dollars a week to five
thousand dollars a week
our goal is to provide an opportunity
for youth who otherwise just would not
be able to afford an overnight camp
experience at no cost
[Music]
my name is erica blue and i'm the chief
executive officer of austin sunshine
camps
i grew up a low-income kid and in
between sixth and seventh grade a friend
paid for me to go to a week-long summer
camp that my parents couldn't afford to
send me to it changed my perspective on
life i know how transformational camp
can be
we were founded in 1928 since that time
we've served over 50 000 kids in the
central texas area
[Music]
here in zilker park is where we have our
8 to 11 year old programming and then we
have lake travis our 12 to 15 year old
campers
and kids come and they're nervous and
some of them are a little scared
but we gather them after check-in and
let them meet their bunkmates
they create a shine contract uh with
their bunk which talks about how they're
going to uphold the shine values as a
bunk together
every day we swim for a couple of hours
in barton springs which is a real
treasure here in austin texas
we go hiking
we focus on programming related to steam
the great outdoors and health and
wellness
[Applause]
one of the most magical parts of camp is
really the connections that are formed
with the campers and the counselors that
come here we make a conservative effort
to make sure that our counselors have
been
in the same situations that our campers
have been in we created the counselor
and training program last year and so we
take our 16 to 17 year olds who have
been past campers and we give them two
years of professional development and we
encourage them to work with kids and try
activities in hopes that one day they'll
come back and be a counselor with us
when they're 18. jada is one of our
amazing counselors in training she found
a home in austin sunshine camps that i
think helped her change the trajectory
of her own life i think she latched on
to programs like austin sunshine camps
where she found a place that she could
get to know other positive role models
hey everybody i'm jada and i'm jordan
and we're with iggy girl
i came here as a camper when i was 12
years old and then when i turned 14 i
started working here as a counselor in
training
also sunshine camp really did change me
and it made a big impact on my life and
being an actual counselor in training i
can actually give these kids that
experience too and just make them have
the best summer that they possibly can
i think that we're making a huge impact
in the central texas community and i
believe wholeheartedly that every kid
deserves that opportunity to have that
same kind of transformation in this
really unique loving fun environment
that is camp
[Music]
you